[Musica]
siamo a roma colosseo e luglio
fa molto caldo e davanti al vigile che è
lì insomma per controllare quello che
c'è da controllare si ferma un taxi ed
esce un signore il signore va verso il
vigile insieme al signore
c'è un pinguino che signore tiene per la
luce un pinguino di quelli che siamo
abituati a vedere nei documentari quelli
dell'antartide un pinguino reale il
signore è vicino al vincere gigena resta
un attimo sconcertato di fronte a questa
scena si rivolge al vigile dice
buongiorno scusi sa non sono di roma
dov'è che posso portarlo vigevano guardi
dice ma lo porti subito allo zoo
all'euro allo zoo dall'eur e come ci
arrivo col taxi a grazie grazie mille
questo si volta prende il pinguino
rimonta sul taxi e sparisce passano tre
ore non fa meno caldo anzi è ancora più
caldo il vigile sta per finire il turno
si ferma al taxi e riscende di nuovo il
signore è anche pinguino
a quel punto il dg lei resta veramente
così dice ma ma mai andato allo zoo dice
sì sì sono andato non dico mai andato
ben tono lo zoo
sì siamo stati dentro lo so ma parlato
con qualcuno si si erano tutti molto
carini e allora mi è piaciuto molto e
adesso dove che posso portarlo perché
questa piccola storia ci fa sorridere
perché ci mostra facendoci fare un salto
in quella che chiamo la posizione
umoristica ci mostra che uno stesso
fatto un pinguino esiste in due mondi di
significato in due cornici di
significato che sono completamente
diversi per il vicino a un problema il
pinguino lì per l'altro figura migliore
amico dell'uomo ora
ci sono cornici di significato che
contengono gli stessi fatte c'è una
parola greca la parola e s'imballa in là
bretta probabilmente già sentita simb
allen dice esprimo il concetto del
mettere insieme del tenere insieme
dell'unire le due parti dalla parola
s'imballa in viene symbola simbolico
tutto ciò che unisce ciò che ci dà il
segno di qualcosa che si e raggruppa
intorno ai simboli della fede i simboli
religiosi simboli e bandiere
le squadre eccetera eccetera c'è
un'altra parola greca la parola e di a
balle in via ballen significa separare
passare attraverso creando una frattura
da di aballay viene la parola diavolo
diabolico
allora ci sono cornici di pensiero
simboliche che uniscono e cornici di
pensiero che dividono ma attenzione
perché ciò che è diabolico ha una
qualità meravigliosa intesa nel senso
diabolico che basta creare una piccola
frattura una piccola diversità di senso
divisione nell'unità perché se non ci
fosse l'unità non la posso io dividere
basta creare una piccola divisione che
poi l'umanità fa il resto l'umanità si
divide cornici di senso e cornici di
separazione l'umanità si divide fino a
il conflitto fino alla guerra di diavolo
è tremendamente efficiente in questo
tremendamente efficace allora per
esempio faccio un esempio che una
cornice di pensiero porti le donne in
arabia saudita ad andare in giro
completamente coperta e vestite è mai
stato un problema per noi ma finché
succedeva lì era un fatto di costume sul
fatto di colore folklore locale diventa
un problema quando quella cornice di
pensiero chiede di portare i suoi
effetti nel nostro territorio
la diversità che lì non ci riguardano ci
spaventano ci preoccupa da noi diventa
oggetto di allarme
entra nel nostro territorio entra nel
nostro spazio cornice di pensiero che
dividono e cornici di pensiero che
uniscono parlando della diversità
parlando dei vari generi sa in che modo
siamo diversi in che modo siamo uguali e
in che modo queste due affermazioni sono
entrambe vere nello stesso momento
ora che anche voi avete conquistato la
posizione umoristica che riesce a vedere
le diverse cornice di pensiero credo che
la risposta che le risposte arrivino un
po da sole ci sono pensieri la stessa
cosa la possiamo vedere in una una
cornice di pensiero che unisce e
un'altra che crea conflitto allora
guardiamo nella cornice simbolica
io posso affermare che siamo
naturalmente diversi che siamo unici ed
irripetibili
certo la biodiversità è un fatto è
necessaria per la vita non può non posso
pensare a un mondo fatto di monadi
uguali tutte uguali a se stesse la
diversità è necessario alla vita oppure
nella cornice separativa di come è certo
che siamo diversi ed è chiaro che noi
siamo superiori a loro quindi mi metto
fuori da una qualsiasi relazione in una
posizione di superiorità di potere gli
esseri umani sono tutti uguali che
l'altra affermazione in che modo siamo
tutti uguali certo che siamo tutti
uguali lo siamo uguali nei diritti
abbiamo e siamo uguali nella dignità
dell'essere umano oppure posso dire
sempre usando il criterio di uguaglianza
che chi non è d'accordo con me chi non è
d'accordo sul fatto che siamo uguali a
torto e quindi a un razzista tensione
ancora il giudizio è la condanna che io
uso per separarmi da quel ti da quella
cornice di pensiero le due cornici di
pensiero sono entrambi vere le due
affermazioni sono entrambi vere perché
raggiungono il loro scopo una del tenere
le cose unite non creare sofferenza non
creare fratture
l'altra quella di proprio di creare il
conflitto di creare la divisione di
creare la condizione per cui un affido a
ragione e badate si dà ragione al 100
per cento totale ragione
osservando i suoi fatti e vuole
prevalere sull'altro
questa è l'origine di tutte le guerre
avete mai sentito qualcuno andare
confrontare con forza e con convinzione
difendendo le proprie opinioni dicendo
io proprio delle idee del cavolo sai le
mie idee proprio non valgono niente sono
delle totali assurdità sono delle idee
strampalate campate per aria per questo
si fa come dico io
avete mai sentito nessuno fare così
tutti si danno ragione di quello che
l'alcol cosa giusta che è bene fare così
questa è l'origine del conflitto cornici
di pensiero e noi sorridiamo perché le
vediamo ora da una posizione che meta
diversa distante umoristica
allora la domanda che mi ha fatto che mi
pone il titolo in che modo le diversità
sfumeranno fino a sparire
mi immagino ho provato a intuire a
lasciare andare un po l'immaginazione
l'intuizione la supervisione e cercare
di immaginare in quali modi allora per
prima cosa vi dico che la guerra
l'ingiustizia e la differenza usata per
creare diversità e conflitto non sparirà
è sempre esistita non sono così ingenuo
da pensare che possiamo andare tutti
verso un mondo dove questo non ci sarà
ma non possiamo fare a meno di vederla
dobbiamo vederle tutte e due le cose
sia l'una che nell'altra adesso proviamo
a vedere in quanti modi potrebbe sfumare
per esempio per saturazione
tra un po ci saremo benché sprecati di
essere chiamati a dividerci su sei
d'accordo non sei d'accordo
sei pro o sei contro sei con me o non
sei con me e libertà di scelta questa no
ad essere ipnotizzati nello nella
necessità di una scelta nella necessità
di prendere una parte contro quell altra
stiamo creando unità
pensando ai nostri figli stiamo creando
un futuro dove varrà la pena vivere o
dove sarà preoccupante vivere per
saturazione per political correctness
per controllo dei social
oggi non posso più fare un'affermazione
insulto un'offesa o un giudizio pesante
usando la diversità senza venire
aggredita senza che qualcuno si dia
ragione scarichi su di me la sua tutta
l'aggressività e tutta la violenza del
suo aver ragione nell'aggredire e nel
dire che io torta cambierà e si diluirà
per il fatto che le trasformazioni del
costume la trasformazione sociale e la
trasformazione della sensibilità è un
fatto continua un po di tempo fa ci si
scandalizzava per il nudo oggi è
dappertutto ci sono attori porno che
diventano opinionisti poteva essere
pensabile 40 anni fa non era pensabile
cambia il senso cambia il senso del
pudore cambia il senso di ciò che è
lecito tante cose stanno stanno
cambiando si stanno modificando noi
osserviamo delle diversità molto diverse
da quelle che osservavano i nostri
genitori e molto diverse da quelle che
osserverà nelle nostre figlie
ora questo è da tenere conto i valori
capitalistici saranno un altro elemento
di diluizione della diversità potere e
denaro sono ormai una religione e il
nome del potere del denaro si mettono
insieme alle diversità anche le più
distanti lo fanno i nostri politici
vuoi che non lo facciano i nostri figli
perché non lo farà nei nostri figlio lo
facciamo noi stessi quando abbiamo la
possibilità ho il vantaggio di
facilitare un nostro progetto un nostro
piano grazie all'unità anche di due
grandi diversità
questo sarà uno degli elementi che
potranno mettere insieme alle cose
un'altra un po più delicato un po più
sottile la formalizzazione dei linguaggi
il nostro modo di comunicare con le app
con i messaggini con le immagini
impoverisce impoverisce la varietà la
grande varietà dell'espressione della
comunicazione diretta e personale tra
gli esseri umani spinge a investire in
forme in modelli
in figure già buffo predefinite e
catalizzando nelle varie nelle varie
forme le semplifica e semplificando le
riduce riduce moltissimo alle sfumature
riduce moltissimo le sfumature riduce
moltissimo le diversità modello questo
modello quello modello che è stato non
che questi comportano entrare in
conflitto ma all'interno ci saranno
sempre più persone che cercano di
appartenere a uno o all'altro le
maschere a difesa dell'intimità se io
investo tutto nell'immagine la vicinanza
la essere visto da vicino per chi sono
tra virgolette veramente diventa
pericolosa perché è difficile che io
possa sentire di essere tanto bello
buono bravo come cerco di far credere
sui social come cerco di venderlo con la
propaganda della mia parte buona della
mia immagine buona verso il mondo che
sarà difficile quindi le le relazioni
diventano rapporti formali c'è una
geometria sentite rapporto a che fare
con la matematica
c'è una geometria delle distanze delle
relazioni delle forme che si assumono
poi far questo non puoi far quell'altro
quando ero piccolo io se andava a casa
di uno si suonava cioè oggi
pensava di passare sotto casa suonare il
campanello non esiste più quella formali
è sparita abbiamo riverenza nel invade
nel chiamare qualcuno o nel nel
presentarci sotto casa sua non si fa più
non esiste più sono maschere che vanno
messe a distanza vanno messe per
proteggere la parte più intima di noi
non entriamo più nell'intimità questo
cercano di non farlo anche i nostri
ragazzi si logorano i pregiudizi
le donne sono forti gli uomini sono
deboli ma chi l'ha detto ci sono tante
donne molto più forte di tanti uomini
pregiudizi che per noi erano erano
validi perché non conoscevamo l'altro
man mano che entriamo in contatto e
facciamo esperienza del
altro attraverso le molteplici occasioni
le tante occasioni che ci sono date più
conosciamo l'altro è più i pregiudizi
cadono cadono proprio in base
all'esperienza moltiplicarsi
dell'esperienza anche l'esperienza fatta
coi social è un'esperienza che che
avvicina che può avvicinare e far cadere
pregiudizi le altre inventate vele voi
cercate le voi provate voi a spingere
osservando diverse cornici di giudizio
le vostre cornici di pensiero le vostre
quelle delle persone intorno a voi
osservare come queste appartengono un
mondo vengono sicuramente da un passato
da esperienze del passato e come sono
destinate a sfumarsi a perdersi andando
avanti progredendo e soprattutto
domandiamoci che mondo vogliamo lasciare
ai nostri figli un mondo di cornici di
separazioni un mondo dove l'altro è il
mezzo per soddisfare il mio bisogno
quindi qualcosa da sfruttare o è
qualcosa da temere da tenere distante
perché mi può portare via qualcosa
ora tutto ciò che avviene in grande
avviene anche nel piccolo i grandi
pensieri grandi conflitti nascono quasi
sempre dalla stessa radice
teniamoci questa posizione umoristiche
atteniamoci questa visione che riesce a
vedere contemporaneamente un fatto
esistere in tutte e due in tutte e due
le cornici allora mentre io e il
pinguino vi ringraziamo voglio farvi
semplicemente notare che nessun pinguino
è stato maltrattato nel corso di questa
presentazione al massimo è stato
frainteso e mi hanno detto di andare
alla fontana di trevi perché lì si
divertirà veramente tantissimo grazie
[Applauso]